merci je passe la parole à antoine
lefèvre pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le ministre
l'édition du monde d'hier souligne l
étonnante unité transpartisane contre la
mise en application de la loi relative à
l'élection des conseillers
départementaux notamment le curieux
tandem paritaire ce nouvel élu à deux
têtes sur un même territoire mais
surtout contre le redécoupage cantonal
force est de constater en effet qu'un
bon tiers sur la moitié des découpages
proposé par les préfets recueil des avis
défavorables des assemblées
départementales même pour celles tenues
par votre majorité y compris dans la
nièvre
mon département de l'aisne n'échappe pas
à cette règle
je le prendrai pour exemple seuls les
parlementaires ont été informés par le
préfet des grands principes de
l'élaboration de cette carte
le président du conseil général
bénéficiant semble-t-il d'une écoute
différencier le projet découpage n'a été
communiqué à l'ensemble des élus qu'une
petite semaine avant l'assemblée
plénière et laisse pantois tous les
maires cette méthode ne peut qu'éveiller
la méfiance des élus minoritaires dans
ce département tenu par votre majorité
par 28 sièges contre 14 soit 2/3 1/3
projetons les résultats du dernier
scrutin présidentiel
et que voit-on de 42 cantons actuels 23
pour votre majorité contre 19 à
l'opposition soit un jeu quasi égal on
passe alors à 21 cantons toujours avec
la même projection et résultat 15 pour
votre majorité contre 6 à l'opposition
soit trois quarts 1 car voilà un
résultat bien troublant vous ne pouvez
cacher les conséquences politiques de ce
redécoupage qui ville sans nul doute à
assurer une majorité un contrôle sans
partage du département enfin le nombre
des cantons amputé de moitié mais dont
l'augmentation de la superficie peut
parfois être multiplié par 4 va 2 facto
raréfier la proposition de services
publics en particulier dans les milieux
ruraux vous proclamiez la
désertification certaines de nos
territoires lorsque l'ancienne majorité
proposé le conseiller territorial
mais en divisant par deux le nombre de
cantons vous leur portez un terrible
coup de grâce quelle jolie pirouette
monsieur le ministre
non seulement vous sous représentés les
territoires ruraux mais vous serez
responsable de leur sous dotation
ultime impact la disparition de nombreux
chefs lieux or ces communes se prévalait
du titre de bourse entre les rendant de
ceux dans ce cas éligibles à la dotation
de solidarité rurale leur permettant
d'assurer justement une partie des
charges de centralité d'aménagement du
territoire poste trésor public caserne
de sapeurs pompiers collège et autres
équipements qui joue un rôle économique
et de services aux populations essentiel
en zone rurale même si vous avez
récemment indiqué le maintien
d'éligibilité de ces communes jusqu'en
qu'en sera-t-il après cette date
monsieur le ministre ma question est
simple si nous avons bien compris que
vous avez pleine conscience des
avantages électoraux que devrait vous
apporter ces redécoupages avez-vous
aussi conscience de tous les effets
négatifs qu'ils auront sur la vie des
territoires
si oui quel cynisme nous pouvons nous ne
pouvons le croire je vous remercie
merci monsieur manuel valls je présente
d'abord je voudrais réparer une erreur
en répondant à monsieur dantec
j'ai oublié de rappeler que c'était mon
collègue philippe martin qui allait
présider la table ronde du 5
concernant les espèces menacées j'en
viens maintenant à la carte à la carte
cantonale ya aucun rapport
le titre du journal le monde auquel vous
faites allusion parlait de la résistance
non pas au scrutin lui-même mais à la
mise en place de la parité or le conseil
général de l'aisne compte six femmes sur
42 aujourd'hui est ce acceptable non
avec le scrutin binominal de demain
elles seront vingt-et-une et la loi du
17 mai apporte des réponses que je crois
concrètes
elle instaure donc la parité aux
élections départementales et elle
permettra ainsi que la voix de chacun de
nos concitoyens et la même valeur
quel que soit le type de découpage de
toute façon ces principes
constitutionnels s'applique un travail
est fait dans chaque département à
partir de critères qui sont connus ce
sont ceux que le conseil constitutionnel
a défini dans sa jurisprudence et qu'il
a signalé dans ses remarques après que
vous
saisi le conseil constitutionnel le
premier principe je les rappeler c'est
la démographie
afin de respecter l'égalité du suffrage
le remodelage s'appuie le plus souvent
pas toujours mais le plus souvent sur la
carte des établissements publics de
coopération intercommunale
lorsque la configuration le permet et
c'est nettement le cas dans le
département de l'aisne les principes
sont transparents ils sont connus de
tous
il passe oui c'est vrai par les
présidents de conseils généraux recevons
aussi quand il ya une demande
les parlementaires à ce jour 55 projets
ont été transmis aux conseils généraux
et 36 votes ont déjà eu lieu
c'est ensuite le conseil d'état qui
examine chacune de ces propositions au
regard des principes qui figure dans la
loi et dans la décision du conseil
constitutionnel
à cette date 32 projets ont été transmis
au conseil d'état dont 24 ont déjà été
approuvées par ce dernier
je peux d'ailleurs vous indiquer que le
conseil d'état a validé le projet de
décret concernant la nouvelle carte
cantonale de l'aisne avec juste une
modification marginal pour une commune
au titre précisément du respect des
critères démographiques vous le voyez le
remodelage la carte cantonale se fait
dans le strict respect de la loi
les principes fixés par le conseil
constitutionnel la loi rien que la loi